hey what's up my name's samuel leeds
listen for the last
four or five years i have been doing a
lot of my property deals
in secret i've not been vlogging them
i've been quietly doing them
and the reason is is because i wasn't
some of these deals
these big deals i've been doing i didn't
feel that i was in a position to be able
to teach because i was
doing it myself first and look buy to
let buying a house rent it out i've been
doing that for 12 years
but over the last few years i've
transitioned
into big deals property development it
all started when i met lord sugar
boom 2017 and i told him that my plan
was to have a thousand houses
and i went over my business plan and he
said it was a stupid plan
i then got mentored by grant cardone and
i moved into property development and
i'll tell you something
i lost money in property development
like around 2017 i was buying bits of
land on option couldn't get planning it
was a
nightmare however over the last few
years i've put together the most
incredible power team
and we've got some really really really
good deals that have made a lot of money
last year we did uh six sites literally
just bought pieces of land on
um on on an option agreement got
planning and then reassigned the option
made hundred thousand pound a deal as
you know we bought the castle
which i've not been talking about much
at all but
boom boom would you look at that this
is the very first time i've ever openly
shared about property development
and in this book it's a little book easy
read
easy read in this book i share
how and right now listen i mean i've
been
i've been keeping so quiet but right now
we have a hundred
million pounds worth of property deals
in the pipeline
we've got six sites going on uh as you
probably know we documented we built
some houses
um and sold them like a year or so back
we've got the castle we've got a lot of
pieces of land in around buckinghamshire
we're building an apartment block right
now in leeds
in yorkshire and it's been a tough ride
because you know why
there are no books like this on the
market
if you want to learn how to do property
development title splitting
how to find pieces of land how to profit
from the planning permission
how to minimize your tax this is nothing
that's why i ended up having to pay 200
000 pounds to grant cardone
to learn how to grow and scale a big
property portfolio
and grant cardone was like come and
invest with me in my deals
in miami florida and he's doing some
great things he's become a great mentor
and a friend as well
but what i've done is i've taken all
these different strategies
off of these successful developers and
i've had to pay hundreds of thousands of
pounds
in mistakes and also in
um in mentoring and i've put everything
into this book which is just gonna blow
i mean you need to read this book
the great news is i'm not even selling
anything to you right now because
this book i have got a deal with amazon
and i've put this book
on amazon kindle right now for a limited
time
amazon only let you do it for like a
very small amount of time like a few
days
but right now it's on amazon kindle for
free
okay so you can download this download
the kindle version
have it on your iphone or on your
computer or on your kindle or whatever
and you can have this for free and you
can study it again and again and again
and again
and honestly i mean i even talk about
lord sugar
in in this book i mentioned lord sugar i
talk a lot about grant cardone
all the things that i've learned from
grant and as he's been mentoring me
um liv cook wrote the forward she's
absolutely incredible
you can see the kind of things look at
this profiting from the planning
um finding land
securing land on option agreements
converting
title splitting commercial to
residential all the stories are in here
not just the stories of how i made money
but in here
that's why it's a gloomy looking buck
it's a gloomy looking buck
because also the stories of how i lost
money
um there's some there's a lot of sharks
in this industry
it's a doggy dog industry and you can
avoid
you can avoid that i mean i spent so
much money
on making mistakes you can avoid that in
this little box so i've written this
and i think it's my best book i think
this is the most
powerful book because the thing is i
wrote barlow rent high in 2016
and barlow went high became a bestseller
sold hundreds of thousands of copies all
across the world
and that was kind of like my journey
from 2009
i bought my first house in 2009 so from
2009 right i've been to 2016
and i talk about hmos lease option
agreements
uh vitalettes deal packaging etc etc
but this talks about what i've been
doing
the last five years since i wrote bilo
in high what deals have i done
it's all in here i'll reveal i've got a
whole chapter
dedicated about my business plan and
honestly
look my property
development business plan and i just put
my whole business plan on there
you can see my entire business plan how
i structure the deals how we finance it
how we find them joint venture
agreements how they work
how we find the investors everything is
all in this book
so it's a free gift this summer
from me to you download it for free you
can get the paperback version if you
want that's 9.99
we can get on kindle right now
completely free and then you'll have it
forever and i really hope that you win
in property development you know it's
it's uh it's a very easy business it's a
very straightforward business
but i've noticed everybody that's doing
making millions
i'm not talking about making a hundreds
of thousands
or making thousands of pounds a month or
whatever i'm talking millions
i've got some friends i talk about in
this book there are billionaires
with a b that's a thousand million but
people that are making that kind of
money
they don't teach they hide they hide
away
they don't teach and there's so many
secrets in this book the secrets of
property development
um you know you could this is like 24 24
000 words
so you can read this in a few hours and
i believe this book will change your
life
so it's a gift from me to you
link in the description get it now
and tell me how you get on and you won't
you won't be able to once you've read
this and you've seen
the deals are available you can't just
live a normal life
you're going to be driving around and
you're just going to be seeing
opportunities everywhere seeing bits of
land
getting planning on them with no money
with an option
and then reassigning them bank six
figure profits i don't talk about deals
in this book
if it won't make you a hundred thousand
pounds profit or or more
i'd even talk about it in this book this
is big deals
anyone can do it it's not difficult
just takes skills and everyone hates on
me for saying that
what do you mean anyone can do it anyone
can do it as long as i have the right
work ethic and they follow the right
training manual
this is a training manual and
you know my results are undeniable
you've seen what happened
when i put books out and started
teaching people to do hmos and rent to
rent what happened
started doing winners on a wednesday
every week bang bang bang bang bang
hundreds and hundreds of people will
start becoming financially free
wait till you get this book in your
hands suddenly what's gonna happen is
hundreds of people are gonna start to
come in millionaires
that's what i believe and these next
couple years i mean what's my business
plan over the next couple years well my
business plan is property development
rather than buying houses is building
houses
building houses this year so if you want
to build houses if you want to make six
figure sites six figures
hundred thousand pounds or more on each
deal that you do get the book
do me one favor though do me one favor
if you're gonna get the book
that's fine but leave me a review okay
i'm moving i'm moving my arm because his
arm's getting tired now
leave me a review on amazon if you enjoy
the book i know you well
download it now and i'll see you real
soon thanks